Yeah.
How do you reconcile studies to chill genetic superseding environment in life
outcomes with your own experience conducting successful psychotherapy?
He,
yeah.
Well,
I'll tell you one thing man did,
I really did come to realize more and more in the last three or four years,
partly I would say from dealing with my own health problems to some degree,
but also watching the health problems that my daughter had.
Um,
I think a lot of what we think of as mental illness is physical illness.
It's a lot more than we think even,
but,
and I think that that is reflected in the genetic studies.
Um,
but I also think I also still think that that doesn't eliminate the role of
learning.
You know?
Um,
people obviously learn and they can learn better or worse and they learn better
when they voluntary voluntarily approach things that are frightening and
threatening and they challenged themselves.
And so,
um,
it's made me more humble,
I would say in some sense,
both as a person and as a psychotherapist because I'm more attuned to the fact
that the apparently psychological difficulties that my clients might be
experiencing,
maybe a consequence of an underlying destabilization of physical health.
I'm really unwilling to discount that.
Um,
even if what they're experiencing is very idiosyncratic.
But it still seems to me that there is credible evidence that exposure to,
to what you would rather avoid is curative.
And so is the weaving together of a coherent and a coherent map or narrative of
your experience.
I believe that those doctrines are solid.
So,
and that's what psychotherapists do.
Essentially,
they help you get your story straight about your past and your present and your
future.
They help you establish your point in life.
They help you lay out a map so that you can negotiate through the territory of
your life,
past,
present,
and future.
And they help you develop strategies to deal with,
to help deal with emergent complexity and the fear that goes along with it.
So,
um,
Michael Tom Rose House a very hard question.
Please comment on young Paulie's.
That's Wolfgang Paulie's.
Who knows?
Mundus hypothesis,
one world hypothesis essentially.
So that,
so Michael,
Tom Bros ass,
sorry,
I got frozen there again momentarily.
Please comment on Yom Paulie's [inaudible] Mundus hypothesis.
Does this correlate with quantum theory solutions to the hard problem?
Eg Penn Rose Hameroff or church or or c h o r I don't know what orange or is.
I know Penrose and Hameroff,
I'm not an admirer of the pen Penrose and Hameroff,
uh,
attempt to reduce consciousness to,
to um,
microtubule function,
quantum mechanics and microtubule function.
I did my best to understand it.
I couldn't,
it seemed hollow to me.
My experience has generally been if I find something in comprehensible and
hollow,
it generally is.
Um,
I've read better books on consciousness,
um,
like the user illusion,
which I really liked.
That's the user illusion by the way.
And Jeffrey Gray wrote a good book on consciousness as well.
Um,
the only Paulie,
I'm not going to be able to answer this question very well cause I'm starting to
get a bit worn out here.
Um,
Wolfgang Pauli and young recognized that,
man,
this is really a complicated problem.
I don't know if I can,
I don't know if I can answer this.
Okay,
let's try this.
Yeah.
God,
it's been years since I've thought about this and wrote about it,
so we'll see how I can do.
Mm.
You can think about this from a perspective of Piaget and Constructivism,
so imagine that what you confront.
Yeah.
What you confront fundamentally in the world is what is unknowable and what is
an unknowable has an intrinsic meaning.
It's both frightening and compelling.
Simultaneously,
it activates Predator detection systems that protect you in the way that a prey
animal is protected by freezing and withdrawal and that sort of thing.
But it also makes you curious so that which you do not understand,
which is something that you can conceptualize as that which has not yet been
made.
Habitable world has an intrinsic meaning.
Yeah.
Now the question is whether the fundamental stuff of the world is that
meaningful unknown or something material.
You can make the case that what we recognize as material is actually a pragmatic
reconceptualization of the meaning of the ambivalent meaning of the unknowable.
Now I know that that's hard.
That's a hard concept,
but imagine you see it depends on whether or not you believe that our
descriptions of material reality are the superordinate
descriptions of reality or whether our conceptualization of material is actually
a form of pragmatic tool use that's oriented towards our survival and this is
not an easy thing to sort out.
It's something that I did try to sort out to some degree with Sam,
you know,
is do we have an objective description of reality and his reality,
something that can be objectively described or are we using a technology that
produces so called objective representations to facilitate our tool use?
And it's a hard question,
right?
Because obviously our advanced technology,
which we use in a tool like fashion is a consequence of our materialists
science.
Which begs the question,
is the science is the fundamental purpose of the science descriptive or
pragmatic?
Now,
I think,
I tend to think it's pragmatic because I think our fundamental problem is a
problem of survival.
So there's a way of looking at the world where the fundamental reality is the
chaotic potential that gives rise to fear and curiosity.
And that's how your nervous system responds by the way.
And see that's interesting to me because I would say,
well,
it's a truism of evolutionary biology that what your nervous system is adapted
to what you're adapted to as a consequence of your three and a half billion
years of evolution is reality.
And that there's no other real way of defining it.
And so the way your brain construes reality is as if what you're confronting
isn't indeterminant chaotic potential that first generate something like
apprehension,
fear and curiosity.
Secondarily,
the apprehension to freeze you so that you don't get eaten or destroyed and the
curiosity to allow you to engage with what's on known and to transform it into
habitable territory,
which in large part consists of tools.
Now,
the onus Mundus that Paulie and young talked about seems to me to be associated
with this idea of that chaotic potential.
And I think that's related to the physicist wheeler's proposition,
that the fundamental reality of the world is information rather than material.
That material is a secondary,
what would you call it?
It's a secondary manifestation of information.
And I think that what we confront in the world,
see,
I don't think we're driven by the past and or determined by the present.
I think what we do is we apprehend the potential of the future,
that chaotic potential of the future.
And,
and I think that that's associated with a Wa Bohu,
which is the chaotic potential that God confronted with the logos at the
beginning of the,
of time in Genesis.
I think the genesis story is a reflection of that fundamental truth.
And I think that that capability characterizes us.
And so the onus Mundus is the informational substrate that constitutes the world
before it's divided into psyche.
So that would be spirit,
that'd be human spirit and consciousness and material.
So there's something underneath that,
and this is what young and Pauline we're driving out in my understanding,
there's something underneath that which is the pre division unity of reality.
And that's something like the Tohu wa Bohu or that tail,
which is etymologically cognate by the way,
with the word Tiamat.
And Tiamat is the goddess that the message put Damien Creator,
God Marduk confronted and cut into pieces and made the world from.
So that's all outlined in maps of meaning,
although not so much the onus Mundus hypothesis.
You know,
and I haven't thought about that for while I wrote about it,
but these were in papers I never published because they were too damn
complicated and I tried to publish them a couple of times for people.
Okay.
But people didn't understand what I was talking about and you know,
I hadn't even thought about,
oh man.
Okay,
well,
okay,
here's a weird thing.
All right,
well the rate at which my camera equipment is crashing seems to be accelerating.
So it appears that discussion of the onus Mundus is,
yeah,
irritating the structure of reality in some manner.
Anyways,
let's get back to it for a minute.
So this is a different way of conceptualizing the world.
I think it's a phenomenological perspective.
So,
and I don't know what to make of it.
So think about it this way,
so it looks like your left hemisphere is specialized for operation in territory
that you understand.
So it's specialized for operation in those places where behavioral patterns have
been made habitual and explicit.
Whereas the right hemisphere is specialized for response to chaos itself to the
unknown.
And what that implies is that the division that's expressed,
for example in the in Yang symbol,
which is essentially chaos and order is actually actually represents something
fundamental about the structure of reality.
Now you might say,
well,
only the structure of reality in so far as biological organisms conceptualize
it,
but I don't know if we can talk about the structure of reality outside the
conceptions of biological organisms.
Like if you're a strict believer in objective material reality in that
transcendent existence of strict material reality,
then you might say,
well you of course you could talk about it because strict material reality
exists in the absence of biology and consciousness.
But it isn't so obvious to me that material reality does exist in the absence of
consciousness because I can't conceptualize what existence would mean in the
absence of consciousness.
Like is there time?
Is their duration,
is their size,
the,
all of these things are relative.
In some sense.
All of these things presuppose a conscious observer even in the materialist
description.
So it looks to me like what reality is,
is this Eunice Mungus,
that union Paulie we're pointing to,
it's chaotic potential.
Now I also think that we treat each other that way.
So if I'm treating you properly,
then I treat you as if you're a moral agent who's actively engaged in the
transformation of the chaotic potential that manifest itself as the dawning of
the future.
And that attracts your attention.
I treat you as if you're an active moral engage.
I'm active moral agent engaged in making the moral decisions that determine how
that potential is going to manifest itself.
And if I don't treat you that way,
then I'm patronizing.
I don't give you your full,
I don't grant you your full stature as an,
as a a sovereign being and I impinge upon your net at your intrinsic value,
the same value that that allows you to claim,
um,
the existence of natural rights and also the presence I would say of natural
responsibility.
So I treat you as if you're well I would say made in the image of God in the
genesis terminology that you are part of the process that turns the toe who are
bold,
who should I never pronounced properly into habitable order.
And I think that that's the onus Mundus and I think that that's reflected in
your neurological structure.
And I think the fact that it's reflected in your neurological structure and in
the neurological structure of animals with this,
you know,
almost universal dual hemisphere neurological structure,
which also by the way is it is something that's necessary even in neural
networks.
Um,
which is where we got the idea for plasticity and stability by the way,
for the,
in the big five aspects,
scale models and the higher order personality factors.
Um,
I think the fact that that bifurcation is reflected in neurology is a reflection
of the fact that it's,
it exists in reality.
Now,
of course,
defining reality is no simple thing.
You know,
it's,
you can think about it as an objective materialist,
but you can also think of reality as the sum total of that which is experienced.
And those aren't the same things.
They aren't the same fundamental presuppositions.
And I think that we've predicated our society in so far as our society is
functional on the proposition that each individual is a sovereign entity.
Um,
what would you say characterized by a spark of divinity that uses the
responsible,
truthful word to confront the chaos of potential and generate the habitable
order?
That is good.
I think we act out.